a magician performing at a birthday
party stands inside a circle of 15 kids
he's going to choose a volunteer and he
wants each kid to have the same chance
of getting chosen fair enough now we
have three methods by which he can do it
and let's just think about whether each
of these methods are fair where each kid
does have where each kid does have the
same chance of getting chosen and if
they're not if they don't lead to each
kid having the same chance of getting
chosen think about why that is the case
so method one the magician starts with
the birthday boy and moves clockwise
passing out 100 pieces of paper numbered
1 through 100 he cycles around the
circle until all the pieces are
distributed he then uses a random number
generator to pick an integer 1 through
100 and chooses the volunteer with that
number so let's just think about what's
happening so there's 15 kids in a circle
so there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 I planned that out amazingly well
I didn't think out if you'll be able to
fit exactly 15 but it worked out so 15
kids in a circle and then he's going to
hand out pieces of paper so he's going
to he's going to let's give 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 and now this
person is going to get pieces of paper 1
and 16 now this is going to get 2 and 17
you're going to keep going around and
round and round until all hundreds all
hundred pieces of paper are going to get
distributed now something to think about
is whether every student every Stewie
every child here is going to get the
same number of pieces of paper I
encourage you to pause this video and
think about that if we just keep cycling
around all the way to 100 does each
child get the same number of pieces of
paper well just think about it in order
to get the same number of pieces of
paper 100 has to be divisible by 15 and
we know 100 isn't is visible
by 15 15 goes into 100 6 times 6 times
15 is 90 and you have a remainder of 10
so what's going to happen is all 15 kids
are going to get 6 pieces of paper and
then another 10 of the 15 are going to
get a seventh piece of paper so they're
not all getting an equal number of
pieces of paper so even though he's
randomly picking an integer between 1
and 100 some of the students are going
to have a higher chance and the other
ones the 10 that have 7 pieces of paper
are going to have a higher chance than
the other 5 who only have 6 pieces who
only have 6 pieces of paper and so I
would say method 1 a method 1 is not
fair let me write this down
not not fair sometimes life isn't fair
but in this in this case it's not fair
where we define fair is the same chance
of getting chosen and that's because
they don't have all have well they all
they all have different numbers of
pieces of paper they're not all of the
students are not equally likely to get
picked let's look at method 2 the
magician starts with the birthday boy
and moves around and moves
counterclockwise passing up 75 pieces of
paper numbered 1 through 75 he cycles
around the circle until all the pieces
are distributed he then uses a random
number generator to pick an integer
between 1 through 75 and chooses the
volunteer with that number so encourage
you to pause this video and think about
whether this one method to whether that
one is fair well method two is the same
as method one except for instead of
using 100 pieces of paper we're using 75
pieces of paper and so we have to think
about is 75 divisible by 15 and 75 is 5
times 15 is 75 so in this situation each
student is going to get 5 pieces of
paper each gets 5 pieces of paper so
they all have an equally likely chance
of getting picked and then he's using a
random number generator picked them so
they all have an equally likely chance I
would say method 2 is method 2 is
indeed is indeed fair they all have an
the same chance of getting chosen now
let's think about method 3 method 3 the
magician starts with the fit with the
birthday boy and moves clockwise passing
out 30 pieces of paper numbered 1
through 30 so they're all going to get
the same number of pieces of paper
they're all going to get two pieces of
paper each 15 children getting 2 pieces
of paper each would be 30 pieces of
paper so that looks reasonable so far he
cycles around the circle until all the
pieces are distributed here so everyone
gets two pieces
he gives number one of the birth to
point number two the next kid and so on
so that all seems reasonable kind of
consistent with method two except not
instead of seventy-five it's 30
and obviously 75 was overkill he could
even hear this is overkill he just
really needs 15 pieces of paper and he
then counts the number of windows in the
room and chooses the volunteer with that
number so the question here is is the
number of windows in the room is it
random and is it evenly distributed so
maybe maybe you could make a case
depending on what building it's in in
someone's house it's somewhat random on
how many video many how many windows
that house happens to have the house
that's happening to host the birthday
party but it's not going to be evenly
it's not going to be evenly distributed
most III don't know they're just
probably there's probably you know
there's probably some if you were to sit
and plot all of the houses that had a
birthday party you'd probably see this
more likely that I know that they have
ten windows than one window or it's more
and definitely more likely that they
have ten windows and then let's say then
then thirty windows or even maybe
fifteen windows even and so it's not
going to be evenly distributed this
really isn't a this this is you know
every house I guess has a somewhat
different number of windows and and the
house that is happening to host the
party is seems to be somewhat random but
it's not going to be evenly distributed
here and I would say it's not a kind of
a a really good random
number generator because it's not evenly
generated and so I would say method
three is not fair not fair the number of
windows is not a really good random
number generator random - good enough a
random number generator we would want
say a number one through 75 where any of
these have an equally likely chance of
getting picked this is it's somewhat
random the number of windows that that
building has but it's it's they're not
all equally equally likely